so very nice tactics I want to go back
to the moment where all these tactics
started so this age six was a very nice
move to give himself this Bishop h6 idea
and as soon as he took Anand who is very
very strong tactician didn't hesitate
here okay welcome everyone to a two
o'clock Sunday kids class the more
advanced class so we have some really
good players here high ranking players
we have so look at this game played
between Viswanathan Anand five-time
world champion and against French
Grandmaster show a lot here and this
game is played a long time ago in 1997
but I just found this game and it's very
interesting and I like the tactics in
this game okay so I think this will be
very nice for you to do the tactics so
you can learn okay white plays d4 black
played d5
okay and now we have which opening we
have here no Scandinavian center counter
yeah so if you place Knight f6 I will be
Scandinavian defence so d5 is also
played and now he takes back the Queen
it looks like not a very good idea
because you're gonna get chased but this
way now white doesn't have that much
control of the center okay there is not
so much control of the center here so
Queen 85 d4 white plays d4 he you know
he got a night out and now he's getting
the control of the center Knight f6
plate again world champion Anand is
white and he's playing a very top
grandmasters or a lot here Knight f3 c6
idea of c6 is to control the d5 square
and if needed Queen can always retreat
on c7 to a solid square Bishop c4
and now he plays Bishop f5 activating
his Bishop activating the bishop and
putting pressure on c2 now white
immediately jumps in into an offense
here with the move Knight e5 Knight is
very active only five and threatening to
take on f7 so the threat is Bishop takes
f7 so black lace is six just to defend
against a threat very natural move and
now on ant is G for very very aggressive
attacking the light square bishop black
goes Bishop g6 what could white
continues with h4 now upon us on h4
their ideas are aged five attacking the
bishop as you can see very very
aggressive play by Anand black develops
9b d7 now he just trying to complete his
development okay and also try to move
this strong night for me five nine ticks
d7 now blocked expect to do that because
you don't want to take back with the
king because if you take back with a
king now your king is going to be in the
middle of the board so it's not a good
not a good situation not a good
situation for the King to be in okay
so Knight takes d7
now why please H five very direct
attacking that Bishop and now there is
only one move to avoid losing the bishop
which moves it that can avoid losing the
bishop please raise your hand if you
have the move that if you see the move
that avoids losing the bishop yes Bishop
b4 correct
because I cannot take back because of
the pin C otherwise I would just take
the bishop so it's a pin I'm being
pinned now to my king so that's why
bishop before is the only move and also
what is bishop before now doing what is
the bishop before threatening thank you
threatening to take the rook okay so he
goes rook h3
now how light was Bishop 2 G 2 attacking
this bishop again
sorry attacking the rook again we see a
very unusual a transfer of the rook here
you don't see too often now rook to e3
bringing the rook to the center
96 moving the night on b6 and now
attacking the bishop Bishop d3 95 okay
I'm not sure if this 95 was the the very
best mode this could be the start of the
problem start of the problem for him
because this Bishop gets a little bit
stuck on g2 so perhaps there were other
alternatives here Bishop d6 or something
so it was 95 now uh none please f3
unexpectedly his rook is under attack
when he plays f3 he says take my rook
I'm not afraid I take back and then I go
kick f2 and I trap the bishop
take my rook so he goes here attacking
the pawn the knight on c3 King f2
activating the king and threatening to
take the bishop bishop c3 pawn takes c3
Queen c3 and now rook is threatening to
take a queen is threatening to take the
rook so black has to play rook be one
yes you can play patient b2 but if you
play we should be too I can just take on
d4 and your Rukh is still trapped here
he likes rugby one because it allows him
to take on b7 okay you can threaten rook
d7 so he goes here Queen d4 and now
again if we take here he's gonna go 93
so that doesn't quite work
I rocked p7
getting a very active Luke on a seventh
rank okay
and now if black makes a mistake here
plays short Castle do you see how white
can win the game here Michael
yes Bishop takes h7 discovery check that
wins the Queen okay and you win the
Queen you're gonna win this game
so he played rook d8 bring the rook into
the game it's still not so not so clear
here it's not like all white is winning
here now it's not so simple yet now
because you cannot take on g2 because
then he plays 93 check taking your queen
if you take Queen takes and next no
black will just cancel the nice position
so black will be just ahead here so he
plays h6 trying to create weaknesses try
to weaken the position and you're gonna
see this move is gonna turn out to be
very very useful
his opponent took yeah if you play g6
then it's just unpleasant this is such a
strong pawn wage here which pawn so you
don't want to allow the pawn so he took
and now the idea here to see it's quite
it's quite possible it's quite possible
black missed the whites move here it's
very very possible he missed it
[Music]
white to play do you see this tactical
idea here yes
Bishop g6 and if it takes the Queen why
are you down on a crimp so you have to
have a mate to just device this to
justify this if you take with a bishop I
have King f8 sir check here
mmm it's very close but it's not
something clear much more clear you have
yes yes look at that tactic check he
cannot take you have to check so he has
to go here check mate
because the rook is protecting the
bishop okay because the rook is
protecting the bishop
and if he plays Knight d7 you take check
check
m8 he cannot go away can I go to g7 he
cannot go to f8 he cannot go anywhere
so he went Knight d7 and now we cannot
use our rook because we're pinned no
what did he play here
Michael correct which would be should be
too I have a check they look d3
I think rookie six is probably winning
as well okay he might be able to castle
there you know or something but this is
simply because now attacks the rook if
you take bishop takes there is also
threat of rook b8 so it's like you know
yeah you can do all the the crazy
tactics or you can just play a quiet
move and win without calculating any of
the tactics which is this he went back
come back we should be three and albeit
his opponent had to resign here because
the whole position is weakened the
bishop is trapped cannot go anywhere if
it goes here we have King g3 Bishop g2
takes bishop here take so you really
cannot do anything here Bishop d3 and he
lost again
so very nice tactics I want to go back
to the moment where all these tactics
started so this age six was a very nice
move to give himself this Bishop h6 idea
and as soon as he took Anand who is very
very strong tactician didn't hesitate
here to find ideas so again how did we
start how did we start this combination
Michael
he takes Bishop d3
yeah he went yeah again don't get any
more with the complicated ideas to
calculate Luke takes you know because he
has castle so just go here he goes back
you should back now Bishop is trapped if
you go bish page three now what is the
move yes excellent move dropping that
bishop okay winning that Bishop it's
very very important okay
because now Bishop cannot go to g2 I
take
can I go to f1 I take so the bishop is
simply going to be trapped okay and now
I cannot do anything got it again this
whole idea wouldn't have work if he
didn't play the move h6 okay if you
didn't have to play the move h6 this
idea wouldn't have worked by playing h6
this idea works now okay now let's do a
couple of more tactics okay before you
start the games okay so I'm going to set
up one position for you this is this
particular one is played by a world
champion mikail towel so he plays
attacking style lots of sacrifices that
kind of chess okay so in this position
he is playing block and this is an
endgame so there's not gonna be too many
sacrifice or anything
Palma de Mallorca and he's playing
against got to look at his name of his
opponent he is playing Medina Medina
tall black to play and win if you have
it please raise your hand when you have
it yeah yes can you do you want King
takes this is the one that's sacrificing
your Quinn yeah but well well not that
sir
that was bad yep well what am i doing I
just think h1 is guarded
you can't just promote it you know that
queen is a problem okay
yes excellent ink ink yes the queen is
very strong when opponent has a very
strong piece what do you do take it
eliminate that piece okay but it's very
concrete here now now how can you try to
promote that pawn if you push the pawn
he catch you if you push the party you
catch you what are you doing here g5
ah to play g4 but then he takes no he
takes with this Michael
look at that move guys night III says
take by night but if he takes the night
he goes further away from the pond and
if he takes the night worried Oh Michael
and he cannot catch him with the king if
he doesn't want to take the night let's
says I don't want that night he tries to
run back to catch it
H to Queen it got it
h1 Queen
I fix from watt into a Quinn no Quinn
because otherwise you won't be able to
win so let's do it again
we take take and we go 93 played by
Michael towel okay now we're going to do
one more tactic before we start the the
games okay white to play and win
just in Clara don't rush it's not like
immediately to check checkmate you're
gonna need to find a difficult move -
yes correct correct
no rush now don't rush now f6 no no no
not so easy
I play f6 and if you check me I escape
on f7 this is the idea but something
needs to be done first okay
something needs to be done first okay
which move needs to be done first to
make this idea work yes King takes
kangjae
yes
[Music]
it's a possibility but it wouldn't
threaten anything immediately something
that will attack something you need to
move that attacks something yes
fantastic yes 9f5
now you have a piece into the game he
cannot take it because you can take the
Queen okay so he has to go here
yes but then you can take the night
nobody I can't use my pong trick so you
wanna you want to use your queen yes
it's a queen move here but where where
to threaten a mate to threaten a mate
yes Queen h5 look at that now threating
a mate on a background if he goes f6 I
go 97 so he has to take not yet not yet
look at the night check he goes here
look at that meeting net now look at
that mating net and you cannot do
anything that is your mating net that
you're gonna do it worth okay attack go
here
check and check check and check my check
and checkmate okay
twenty-eight
the other night the difference now I
have my night in you know so I can
probably suck check check check mutt
Chuck Matt yeah all right
so yeah this is very interesting you
sacrifice you check and then you don't
go with the Queen right away we do go
with the Queen either way sf6
guys this is what most people would do
and then after f6 suddenly there is a
escape square so it wouldn't work okay
so that's why we play this this and it's
really nice idea check and mate
okay great job guys
[Music]